we're learning more about the victim of  a deadly shooting in the west part of  town it happened early sunday morning at  pt's place near charleston and decatur  police say 28 year old timothy hartley  was shot and killed by 24 year old  anthony balderas  when questioned by officers he told them  he didn't remember the shooting  apologize for what he did those closest  to the victim  describe him as a hard-working kind man  always funny always joking never mean to  anybody hard worker amazing worker  amazing friend even though you guys may  have not known him  he was an amazing man he didn't deserve  to go out that way  a gofundme account has been set up in  hartley's name we have a link attached  to this story up on our website